[Musique]
chaque
exceptionnellement solide à votre chef
de bord
cette douleur est le vrai bonheur
bonjour à la base et cela dit cela dit
un voleur de billets alors ça c'est pas
bien d'abord s'est pas joint ses preuves
les attaques personnelles
à l'écouter il se prête à ce jeu là et
fille se portent à la caricature contre
l'herbe y est passé s'il ya une tête de
contrôleurs de billets pour lui je suis
arrivé au ministère de l'agriculture
donc la fnsea chômeurs avait donné une
grande réunion et j'y suis allé il y
avait une grande banderole d'un bout à
l'autre de la salle où il était écrit et
dit on espère meilleur olic au ministère
donc j'ai dit ça tombe bien que je sois
ministre de l'agriculture parce que
comme j'ai affaire à des porcs on se
croirait au salon de l'agriculture de
paris
mais vous allez voir que cette fois est
beaucoup plus étranges
elle rassemble son lot de bizarreries
qu'on ne voit qu aux etats unis
ici des lamas déguisé en carriole en
grappe de raisin
ou en locomotive participe à un concours
d'élégance
après la photo souvenir cooper et son
père vont récupérer la viande lacs ont
gelé et manger du zèbre dans les mois
qui viennent à ton premier elle il faut
faire le deuil de cet animal même si tu
l'as tu es tu dois quand même lui rendre
hommage car la vie de la valeur c'est
peut-être difficile à comprendre mais
oui j'aime ces animaux c'est pour ça que
je les tue à l'autre bout du dôme des
bruits étranges se font entendre
c'est le concours du meilleur cri de
poulet
vous citez jacques chirac d'ailleurs
petite explication j'en viens m'amuser à
la fin de la foire qu'on compte les
bouses que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on peut pas faire le bilan de ce qui
nous arrive maintenant on va voir
l'espoir de pouvoir et ouvrir les
discothèques on est très heureux de
réouvrir de mars
et oui il y à une erreur que le
bescherelle a relevé sur twitter nous ne
voudrions pas casser l'ambiance mais le
participe passé de rouvrir est rouvert
et pas réouvert c'est vrai pourtant
certains internautes conteste lusage
fait loi cette mais ça sonne mal réverb
à s'imposer affaire à suivre
les paris sont ouverts et vos mélodies
vous avez la foi la foi
j'ai eu une fois m allez vincent dias ne
s'est pas le fait c'est le même mot oui
en fait saisie
aujourd'hui vous avez 88 ans je me
permets de le dire depuis quelques jours
sur 7 oui parce que j'ai tourné en
italie par exemple où j'ai vu des
actrices comme lucia bosé comme adriana
asti qui trônaient des rages et pouvant
telle mesure soit années ainsi tournage
le showbiz et hendaye mais pourquoi le
dise notre âge mais pourquoi alors se
faisait pas en france maintenant ça se
fait en france
je trouve ça d'une grande vulgarité est
ce que les choses ont changé dans le
dans le comportement et bien écoutez
leurs comportements j'en parlais l'autre
jour avec marlène schiappa c'est
toujours pareil à l'assemblée nationale
il plus encore décrit fontcaude cot cot
ou alors ils poussent des cris des
insultes surtout après le déjeuner quand
ils ont bu un coup
[Applaudissements]
elle m'a dit une chose extraordinaire
c'est que le président de l'assemblée
nationale a pris une décision très
intelligente il a décidé que ceux qui
insultait les femmes à l'assemblée on
leur retire est la moitié de leur
rémunération
le haut à la fin du mois vous
applaudissez âge applaudi alors là dès
demain je trouve que c'est formidable
mais dans divers de l'amour comme on
apprend le français en faisant un
[Rires]
certain que quand on fait de la mort en
fait vous parlez beaucoup de ça mais
vous revenez sur la question qui est
surtout les plus kitsch j'étais en train
de faire une blague
j'ai l'habitude de dire quelque chose je
suis passé je peux le dire à la télé
huawei alors si c'est insultant non
c'est pas insultant c'est un peu pas du
tout ma voiture c'est comme une femme
alors oui non alors dans alors voilà
alors donc alors vous avez des idées non
vous avez raison d'hésiter
alors on la touche pas aux quais et
après il ya d'autres choses qu'on fait
pas avec je m'apprête pas on ne monte
pas dessus non c'est dans normalement
l'afrique
on entend encore parfois que les femmes
sont compliquées qu'elles sont
capricieuses et bien les voitures aussi
visiblement oui c'est un débit cas c'est
vrai manque de respect total pour la
voiture ce que voulait dire l'amour en
français et en répondant à la question
parce que comment on apprend de l'amour
en français comme s'il avait une
différence en anglais you n'a pas pas
vraiment chérie c'est le même but le
plaisir de vous rappeler de cette jeu
quand on était petit le carré dans le
carré le rond dans le rond c'est un peu
comme ça sophie n'est pas des triangles
vraiment pas suivant en tout cas ces
luttes et l'italie c'est l'italie qui
remporte ce 65e concours de l'eurovision
étaient honnis
nous organisons c'est le meilleur
classement pour la france depuis 1991
on est deuxièmes des oeuvres aux visions
abondamment bravo barbara ces six
proches du but on est
les italiens sont au coeur d'une
polémique une image diffusée en direct
semble montrer l'un des membres du
groupe en train de consommer de la
cocaïne
la vidéo fait le buzz sur internet et
suscite des réactions d'indignation le
principal intéressé a d'ailleurs dû
démentir toute prise de drame on parle
pas du groupe madness km de cette
polémique de la cocaïne ou pas voilà
c'est ça c'est autre chose
oui puis c'est surtout alors déjà mois
prochain peut aisément ce que je trouve
ça c'était des choses qui me concerne
pas et surtout ce que ce que je trouve
ce qui est réel c'est que ce sont des
gens qui ont été élus et par le public
et par le jury dont caprez si ils se
droguent si ils ont mis leurs slips à
l'envers ça va être quoi mon problème